playing a title player night night 64
from Jamaica okay so we have a queen's
gamma declined
um I'll stay
within my usual territory
I'll play Knight D7
this move sets up the elephant trap it
takes takes takes I take oh no my queen
but oh yes because I win it back and
then
uh black is off a piece if uh if white
were to take
a light doesn't take so play this
um Bishop D3 or 903 are both playable
and we do have a version of the Queen's
Gambit declined exchange variation
it doesn't make sense for me to go for
Cambridge Springs now that there's no
more tension between uh the pawns like
there's no possibility the fifth ring
will open
so I'll play in a more traditional sense
Bishop B7
it's such a streaming night in Italy hi
Eric
oh hello it's a plan planta Ray
okay so we're going into a line that
I actually haven't played in a while but
um one of the main ideas
actually starting with rookie Eights uh
lady is to put the nylon G6
now what usually goes for this minority
attack
I'll throw an A6 because why not
oh the queen is not on C2 yet
I don't think it makes a huge difference
though
usually the Queen's on C2 and I'm like I
I would play Bishop D6
uh if I plays this I probably taken Play
Bishop D6 anyway
um the main plan for black is to play
Bishop D6 and then H6
and make it so I'm essentially getting
this bishop off the board
and that's the useful thing about the
Knight controlling these squares
Wing B3
I don't think I've ever had this
position before
but I don't think it makes much of a
difference
I'll still go for this
it's Jonathan Sampson
welcome back
been watching a lot of Eric Rosen
recently nice
I have been posting a lot more on
YouTube recently
I think I've posted a video every day
this month
I posted a reel on Instagram this
morning
first time in over a month
I recently got a new laptop that has
like a faster
editing capabilities
I was trying to figure out Final Cut Pro
and how to like more effectively make a
vertical video
[Music]
so each six is coming next and the
reason why I played Bishop D6 first is
because after H6 uh if takes I can take
with queen and then I'll be in better
shape to attack
I do loosen this Knight
uh if white were to take I take back on
G5
now I'm threatening this this Pawn is
overworked
I do Outsource some of my editing
yeah actually shout out to Jonathan
trance
a decent amount in recent months
um hiding potatoes in my videos
but I still enjoy the editing process
and sometimes it's nice to
um
to just go through the whole creative
workflow
in my age too
a few moves come to mind like Knight H4
I mean maybe I just played an H4 right
away
like setting up
when you hear I'm not too scared of
Knight G4 because Queen G5
it just seems like most of White's
pieces abandoned the king side
and most of my pieces are aimed at the
king side
so
it's looking nice
it's emberg hey Eric not to fear you
have one thing over the Eric boxing
trophies yeah if only bots can be
programmed to prefer certain positions
and checkmates
it would be interesting to like make a
bot that's optimized for achieving rows
and trophies
but then maybe it would play like the
egg or the beach cafe every game
and still made every game
okay Rook C1
so another piece is abandoning the king
what is this
I mean I could I can take and then take
I think maybe white yeah white had to
miss this move
now G2 and E3 are both hanging
knife three is an idea
expecting
uh this is made into
Tech and
yeah it's uh
I feel bad for the king
was a victim of negligence
all of its friends just
went away from it
that was a fun game I mean this is
this was maybe a more extreme example of
what can go right in the Queen's gamut
declines
and how to get a really like strong
attack
usually it doesn't go this well but um
it's nice to at least show this
instructive plan I think a lot of people
might learn that queensgam declined and
maybe get to this position after
castling and then just not know what to
do
but it's helpful to kind of have these
middle game Maneuvers in store
and I can show the main line real quick
because there's a cool bit of
preparation
imagine like plays Queen C2 there's a
lot of ways that we could transpose into
this position usually white plays this
move earlier
I'd still go for this
and then if white goes for the minority
attack which is kind of the main plan
then I go for Bishop D6 B5 takes takes
I have H6
it'd be very similar to what we just had
in the game
it takes I'm happy to take here
and then there's not much I can do with
the bishop and G-Force coming
so the main line is takes takes
and there's an interesting tidbit about
this position
um let me toggle the engine
so at first engine will say White's
doing really well
but then you let it think
and it realizes that
it's not so simple and it initially
suggested E4
um now white can white can start with
taking and then play E4
and at first it looks bad for black
because E5 might be coming if takes and
takes
but there's a really cool move in this
position Knight F4
and I discovered this
several years ago
but the point is after this
black temporarily loses a bishop but
then Queen G4 lacks winning back
material with a better position
this is already much better for black
yeah white can survive with 91 takes
threatening mate and then F3 defending
but then after it takes takes and then
Queen D7 or queen E6
oh that's going to be winning the pawn
so
okay hopefully people learned a thing or
two
I might put this game on YouTube
out to attack and the Queen's gamut
declined
maybe make attack all uppercase in the
title